les morissette biologie spécialisée
bonne faire marin fonctionnement des
écosystèmes
vous êtes à rimouski madame mauricette
merci d'être là bonjour ainsi roi alors
journée mondiale des océans il ya eu des
colloques aujourd'hui un rapport se dé
paix de l'onu en un mot ça va pas bien
qu est-ce qui va le plus mal selon vous
c'est un bilan de santé instrus deuxième
bilan de santé on en avait fait un 2017
ya quand même des choses qui vont bien
les aires marines protégées qu'on a
réussi à augmenter un peu partout sur la
planète bon il ya certains endroits où
il ya une bonne gestion des pêcheries et
puis une bonne gestion des polluants
mais sinon vous l'aviez dit ce qu'on
voit dans le rapport c'est surtout des
dossiers sur lesquels ça s'est pas
améliorée au contraire le bruit sous
marins ça c'est pas un mini améliorer
tout ce qui est sûr pêche dans la
majorité des cas ça s'est pas améliorée
sinon la pollution par le plastique la
perte d'habitat est évidemment tout ce
qui est conséquences des changements
climatiques ce sont des dossiers qui ne
se sont pas améliorées donc un bilotte
un bilan de santé assez troublant le
quatre ans plus tard avec ce deuxième
rapport le bon ce qui est peut-être le
plus inquiétant c'est le réchauffement
de l'eau parce que bon le plastique
c'est pouvant table on voit des photos
mais à la limite on peut se ressaisir
allez l'enlever arrêtez d'en mettre si
si je vais être optimiste mais le
réchauffement
qu'est ce qu'elle est la conséquence du
réchauffement de l'eau des océans
il ya un pas qu'il y aurait pas quelque
chose qui arrive quand l'eau se
réchauffe il ya des efflorescences
d'algues toxiques y en a de plus en plus
juste aux niveaux physique l'expansion
terme et contribuer quand l'océan se
réchauffe à l'augmentation du niveau de
la mer l'augmentation du niveau de la
mer par
par parenthèse c'est le facteur pour
lesquels c'est complètement il est
irréversible
on pourra jamais baisser le niveau d'eau
donc pour la plupart des autres à faire
si on se ressaisit comme vous dites on
peut peut-être renverser la vapeur pour
l'augmentation du niveau de la mer c'est
impossible pour le réchauffement ça va
être très difficile puis qu'est ce que
ça fait mais ça fait des espèces qui
perdent leurs habitants qui vont changer
de région parce que l'eau est plus à la
bonne température pour eux ça fait de la
pollution supplémentaire ça fait que les
courants change
le gulfstream dans l'atlantique et 30%
moins puissant qu'il était depuis depuis
lors son histoire donc le changement de
la température de l'eau ça va aussi
affecter toute la machine clim la
machine climatique les événements météo
extrêmes donc toi au final c'est nous
les humains qui allons aussi en subir
les conséquences
je voyais des images pendant que vous
parliez des coraux qui blanchissent donc
des coraux qui meurt et j'écoute un
documentaire hier et la personne disait
si les arbres sur la planète se
remettait à blanchir comme les coraux on
parlerait de ça tous les jours aux
nouvelles or on les voit moins les
coraux mais c'est épouvantable quel est
le danger de la perte des corons c'est
toujours plus facile de parler d'une
coupable anc de ce qui est caché sous la
surface où la surface mais oui
effectivement le blanchiment des coraux
mais c'est toute une biodiversité
c'est cette structure là dans un
écosystème qui qui nous aide à freiner
les changements climatiques parce qu'ils
sont capables de capter une partie du
carbone atmosphérique
c'est une structure de biodiversité dans
laquelle il ya des milliers sinon des
millions d'espèces qui survivent et puis
qui nous qui nous servent nous les
humains en termes de produits et
services en termes de tourisme pour
aller voir cette beauté là en terme de
découvertes médicales il ya des secrets
cachés dans nos récifs coralliens dans
nos océans qu'on n'a même pas encore
découvert donc les protéger c'est pas
c'est pas seulement parce que c'est beau
c'est crucial à notre survie puis
souvent le drame c'est que ça se passe
sous la surface qui on est on est pas
vraiment conscients de ça parce qu'on le
voit pas comme si c'était une forêt
parce que le blanc
shima c'est comme vous dites c'est que
le corail absorbent plus de chaleur
parce que l'eau des plus chaudes
d'ailleurs on va voir un graphique le
lot n'arrête pas de se réchauffer depuis
25 ans l'eau vous le voyez la moyenne
1971-2000 lausanne c'est ça monte vers
le haut comme vous dites ça serait
étonnant que ça sera anvers mais donc je
disais donc le blanchiment c'est la
première étape mais ça peut aller
jusqu'à la mort du co oreilles
ben oui parce que quand le blanchiment
des récifs coralliens en fait c'est que
un corail normalement c'est une symbiose
en deux organismes et puis c'est une
plante et puis c'est une algue et puis
il ya un autre organisme qui vivent en
symbiose vie quand les le blanchiment se
produit en fait c'est que l'algue quitte
le corail et la machine donc qui sait
comme s'il manquait une pièce dans votre
moteur
donc c'est cette machine lac et leurs
récifs coralliens ne fonctionne plus
puis ça fait pas seulement de pertes de
couleurs mais ça fait la perte de
fonctionnement d'un écosystème qui est
bien rodée qui supporte comme habitat
des centaines d'autres espèces donc
c'est ce qui arrive quand on parle de
blanche mais bon les gens quand on parle
de soi se disait en australie c'est le
médecin c'est partout la dent dans
toutes les mers de décor au plus près de
chez nous vous êtes à rimouski on
regarde derrière vous c'est magnifique
l'état de nos ac a indiqué ce qu'on peut
en dire
l g et ça je le constat qu'on peut faire
c'est qu'on n'est pas isolé ici sur le
saint laurent n'est pas isolé sous une
cloche de verre on n'a aucune raison
d'avoir la prétention penser qu'on est
meilleure qu'ailleurs ça vaut mieux
qu'ailleurs
quand on parle d'acidification des
océans de zone morte où il n'y a plus
assez d'oxygène de pollution plastique
peu importe l'enjeu dans ce fameux
rapport leur de 1200 pages qui est sorti
aujourd'hui on pourrait refaire le même
bilan d' état de santé pour le saint
laurent puis ça serait pas mal similaire
donc on peut pas dire en se couchant née
meyer noura on s'occupe mieux de tutorat
de ce que on est tous interreliés là ça
serait réconfortant de pouvoir faire ça
mais malheureusement on peut pas le
faire on n'y a pas de ailleurs dans ce
genre de situation là on peut pas se
dire ans et ailleurs ça se passe dans le
pacifique
ça se passe chez nous aussi pour la
plupart des enjeux donc non on peut pas
se coucher le soir l'esprit tranquille
en se disant que c'est pas grave je le
disais le plastique et ce genre de
choses d'un contrôle plus évident pour
le réchauffement de la planète ça nous
renvoie sur têt cet énorme dossier est
réel oui puis pour pour le réchauffement
climatique comme pour les autres enjeux
océanique je pense que ce qui est
important de faire présentement c'est de
penser à ce qu'on fait de revoir notre
façon de faire puis si la pandémie a été
utile pour une chose c'est peut-être de
nous présenter des modèles où justement
on revoit notre façon de travailler on
fait du télétravail on ne fait plus
d'achat local
on a revu nos modes de transport parce
qu'on n'avait pas le choix
peut-être que ça s'il ya un côté positif
à la pandémie c'est nous avons peut-être
appris à utiliser ce genre de modèle le
plus j'espère que c'est ce qui va rester
après coup dans notre façon de faire
parce que on peut travailler ans on peut
on peut freiner sa ou même de renverser
la vapeur mais il va falloir travailler
faire puis dans le rapport à ce qu'ont
conclu
c'est que la seule façon d'y arriver
c'est en deux mots coopération
collaboration
donc il va falloir travailler ensemble
c'est seulement comme cela je pense
qu'on va être capable d'avoir des
résultats significatifs n'est pas de
magie le non plus les morissette
biologiste spécialiste des mammifères
marins du fonctionnement des écosystèmes
et vous nous parliez de rimouski c'est
magnifique derrière derrière bouyahia va
faire chaud aussi en voilà une espèce de
brouillard mais on a le vin ça aide
beaucoup
bonne fin de journée au roi